je reçois joaquim pueyo ancien député et
maire socialiste de la ville d'alençon
en normandie
[Musique]
bonjour joaquim pueyo
merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui en
direct sur rt france alors les après les
mesures de confinement le week-end dans
les alpes-maritimes
on attendait la décision aujourd'hui
pour dunkerque emmanuel macron on l'a vu
veut faire du cas par cas mais les
français redoutent maintenant de devoir
rester chez eux le week end que pensez
vous de cette stratégie
tout dépend du denaisis dans les
territoires où deux décident ans est
inférieur à 100 doses supérieures à 200
effectivement je suis assez favorable
pour que chaque territoire puissent
s'adapter par rapport à ce qu vide
n'oubliez l'idée de dire on va mettre
des contraintes supplémentaires pour
éviter la contagion
dans certains territoires je trouve que
c'est plutôt pragmatique en accord avec
les élus je crois qu'ils vont du taux de
la concertation a dunkerque les les élus
ont déconcerté y aura des décisions qui
seront prises aujourd'hui dans notre
histoire de l'incidence est nettement
inférieur donc le système actuel le
couvre-feu 18h et suffisant mais
effectivement il faut s'adapter par
rapport à la circulation du coc vidot me
fait de ne pas généraliser
ils ont un confinement ou des
contraintes sur toute la métropole
je trouve que c'est plutôt une bonne
chose alors justement a contrario en
normandie dans votre territoire il ya
peu de circulation du virus à ce qu'on
pourrait envisager linverse par exemple
à ouvrir certains restaurants je crois
qu'il faut rester prudent pour l'instant
une somme sur un plateau qui baissent
donc c'est une bonne chose
attendons effectivement que l'école et
max infras l'aurais fait parce que je
crois qu est la vaccination est
importante
absolument renforcer la coordination et
si effectivement le dos et se est de
plus en plus bas là on pourrait
effectivement envisager un desserrement
des contraintes actuelles
on va parler de la vaccination
auparavant je voudrais vous faire réagir
sur 7
déclaration de la commission européenne
qui a épinglé hier l'allemagne et la
belgique pour des restrictions qui ont
été jugées disproportionnées regardez
c'est dans l'intérêt des états eux mêmes
qui nous faisons confiance pour trouver
des solutions sans que nous soyons
obligés de recourir à des moyens
juridiques
est ce que cette mise en garde est
justifiée selon vous on ne sait pas se
justifier parce que effectivement
l'interdiction de les frotter à son vert
sauf que les voyages doivent être
nécessaires pour se déplacer d'un pays à
l'autre
certains pays hôte est un peu plus loin
la mesure où le vide et est important
d'eau moi j'ai pas condamner les six
pays
fectivement qui n'ont pas forcément
respectée à la laine la décision de la
commission européenne j'espère que les
chefs de gouvernement pourront pourront
répondre
disons aux observations de la commission
européenne moi je te comprend
effectivement que la belgique ou
l'allemagne ait pris d'autres
dispositions
donc moi j'ai vu je pense que les pays
devraient avoir un peu plus de liberté
même si le cadre européen
ou bien sûr est important alors parlons
justement de la vaccination on l'avait
dans ce reportage précédent des
personnes âgées prioritaires qui
n'arrive pas à prendre rendez vous c'est
le cas en bretagne on l'a vu quelques
ondées team d'alençon dans votre ville
pour l'instant si vous voulez on a 200
de vaccination d'un hôpital et d'une
salle communale
les puces simple 15 ans font vacciner
font une première injection la deuxième
injection commence le var le sens de
vaccination fonctionne mais on a deux
questions la première question si la
tranche d'âge 65 ans ce sont quinze ans
pour l'instant n'y a pas de visibilité
dans les prises de rendez vous et puis
faut absolument qu'on termine cette
première phase
j'espère qu'on pourra la terminer au
mois de mars donc il faudra avoir un peu
plus de nose si on veut vacciner des
pubs 115 enfin toutes celles et tous
ceux qui sont volontaires et ils sont de
plus en plus important donc on a
plusieurs questions à se poser
les la suite d'un évidemment et puis la
tranche d'âge importante qui attend
effectivement pour 30 des rendez-vous
alors il ya eu des quelques difficultés
dans l'ensemble ça fonctionne bien je
vois notre département de bande le taux
de vaccination n'est pas négligeable
mais je suis dit j'espère qu'on va avoir
davantage de lisibilité sur le nombre de
doses que les centres de vaccination
pour obtenir la normandie c'est une
région où il ya beaucoup d'éleveurs
certains sons sont très en colère on l'a
vu après la décision de la mairie
écologistes de lyon d'imposer des repas
sans viande dans les cantines et quel
est votre sentiment à vous sur cette
décision controversée alors moi je suis
pas lyon je connais pas les contraintes
des logos des des restaurants scolaires
moi je vois ce que j'ai pu faire
on a les mêmes peu près tous les
restaurants scolaires ont les mêmes
contraintes de la france moi j'aime bien
sûr j'ai servi des repas dans des salles
de classe j'ai fait des menus eu ce
froid avec de la viande bien évidemment
puisque le la loi et galine prévoit déjà
un menu végétarien une fois par semaine
c'est ce qu'on pratique donc
effectivement la décision de la mairie
de lyon et controversé dont j'ai entendu
les arguments disant que c'était pour
permettre à tous les enfants de manger
mais effectivement on ne sait pas trop
pourquoi on peut manger du poisson et
pas forcément de l'avion donc il ya des
interrogations et je le comprends
également sacré mano cdu mairie
écologistes donc c'est pour ça que cette
suspicion de dire ce que c'est pas une
décision doctrinaire par rapport aux
véganisme ou si c'est une décision
pragmatique le maire a répondu que
c'était plutôt pragmatique donc j'en
prends à mais c'est vrai que l'a indiqué
d'ailleurs que dès que les conditions le
permettront et viendra des menus
classiques
moi je pense faisons attention parce que
il faut pas que les menus soient l'objet
de doctrine ne se croit que on a
effectivement déséquilibre alimentaire
nada protéines à mettre en place dans
les cantines dialogue il ya le côté bio
qui est des circuits pour également
c'est ce que nous faisons sur les
territoires et donc j'aimerais que cette
controverse dont mal à mon avis alors
cette polémique divise jusqu'au sein de
la majorité on l'a vu le chef de l'état
a fait une déclaration hier alors qu'il
était en déplacement en côte-d'or auprès
des agriculteurs jean castex également a
dû recadrer ses ministres regarder le
changement ne peut se faire du jour au
lendemain
nous sommes engagés collectivement dans
une très grande transition
il faut de tout remettre des
légumineuses avoir aussi une viande de
qualité
rester dans un modèle complet
d'alimentation - nous alimentons les
polémiques autoportée mieux nous nous
portons les montants et les politiques
nous nous portons il a le sens de la
formule jean castex
est-ce que c'est pas une décision qui
doit se prendre au niveau national
finalement puisque ça concerne tout le
territoire les laissons les
collectivités locales de décider si
leurs propres compétences
mais je suis d'accord avec le présent et
publie il faut des menus équilibrés
effectivement mettre du bio les circuits
courts joue un rôle important et de bain
stigmatiser la viande bien évidemment
qui est important pour pour les enfants
des écoles donc moi je suis d'accord
avec la position officielle
la venue du président de la république
et du premier ministre et les
controverses doit pas avoir lieu
sélection c'est dommage que fictive moi
ça a pris cette ampleur
je pense que pourra et on peut faire
autrement en mettant par exemple des
repas froids à tour de rôle pour les
enfants on l'a fait nous sort alençon et
les parents comme les les enseignants
sont plutôt satisfait tout en gardant
l'équilibré alimentaire
alors deux jeunes de 14 ans ont été
tuées en deux jours dans l'essonne
on le sait il ya eu une sens d'une
centaine de rixe entre bandes rivales
dans ce département l'an dernier ça a
fait réagir à la classe politique voyez
tout d'abord celle de robert ménard le
maire de béziers on en parle après la
sauvagerie s'installent des bandes
rivales
une adolescente tuée d'un coup de
couteau on n'est pourtant pas dans une
favela
on est en france votre réaction sur ce
qui se passe en en essonne écoutez cccd
fait existe et est très gras on a
effectivement des cités qui sont quand
grenet par des bandes rivales par des
jeunes adolescents il ya plusieurs
questions qu'on doit se poser
il ya les effectifs de la police la
présence policière il ya également une
question qu'on oublie de poser et la
responsabilité des parents ce sont des
adolescents qui sont en prise en charge
par leur famille il faut quand même des
associés il faut les interpeller il faut
les rencontrer c'est pas normal que que
des jeunes se bat avec des morts il ya
eu deux morts l'a récemment
l'année dernière on a eu également des
morts en 2018 également
de nombreux blessés dom là on voit que
c'est signer des difficultés très très
grave et la prise en charge de deux
adolescents doit être considéré dans
notre pays parce que on voit trop de
violence actuellement l'état de droit
remise en go bien évidemment et c'est
dramatique pour les familles des
victimes
donc moi je pose des questions concrètes
effectivement il ya un problème de
l'ascension pour pour les adolescents et
là il ya la présence de 2,2 de la
plaisir de travail multidisciplinaire où
est fait entre l'éducation nationale les
travailleurs sociaux
et puis et puis la liste nationale et
puis il ya également la responsabilité
des parents qui lui paraît absolument
importante contexte de violence ans
d'ailleurs au niveau national même dans
les régions rurales
est ce que c'est le cas en normandie est
ce que vous vous constatez aussi ces
phénomènes de hausse de violence moi je
suis donné un département avec des
villes moyennes comme alençon on voit
pas ces phénomènes de violence début il
ya bien sûr des agressions c'est pas lié
à des bandes
heureusement on a eu des agressions
individuelle mais pas lui à des bandes
n'y a pas de pente située tél selon ma
connaissance mais je pense qu'il faut
faire de la prévention
il faut renforcer par exemple la police
de proximité dans les quartiers
il faut renforcer également la médiation
nous avons des médiateurs qui écoute et
qui essayent de d'anticiper et puis
associé effectivement tous les acteurs
sociaux sur un territoire en
responsabilisant également les parents
parce que je crois que c'est important
de rappeler que les parents ou un rôle
fondamental dans l'éducation de leurs
enfants encore jeunes
le rôle de la prévention de la
délinquance un comble justement aux élus
locaux
wiltord la tranquillité local c'est un
combo élus locaux nous nous avons une
police municipale ou même mis en place
effectivement des mets des médiateurs
également una une association qui fait
de la médiation
lorsqu'il ya des cons ville voisine a
lorsqu'il ya des occupations de halls
d'immeuble qui empêche la vie
quotidienne des habitants donc il la met
le la prévention est importante mais
n'oublions pas également
il ya des faits qui sont inacceptables
et que par conséquent oui je n'ai pas
peur de dire la répression est également
très complémentaire à la prévention dans
certains cas et c'est le cas ici avec
des violences qui sont inacceptables qui
nie qui nous effraie nous effraie qui
effraie les familles également donc il
est temps de reprendre en main tous ces
sites et dans lequel effectivement
l'état de droit à beaucoup de
difficultés a été exercée alors
justement gérald darmanin a décidé
d'envoyer une centaine de policiers et
de gendarmes en renfort en essonne il a
aussi parlé de la responsabilité des
réseaux sociaux qui selon lui favorise
et ses règlements de compte regarder
aujourd'hui le défi que nous devons ça
défie d'abord bien sûr de sécurité pour
lutter contre ces rixes et bandes qui se
multiplient éviter l'année terrible de
2016 rio jusqu'à neuf décès de jeunes
dans ces confrontations de banks avait
plutôt tendance à baisser mais nous
voyons que les terribles faits
d'actualité nous rappelle que c'est
toujours très présent du fait notamment
du mimétisme des réseaux sociaux que
nous devons évidemment prendre en compte
et des messagerie crypté que nous
n'arrivons pas toujours à obtenir plus
que la loi nous permet pas d'intervenir
sur les messageries cette question des
réseaux sociaux est une question
cruciale selon vous pour expliquer la
montée de ces violences ont le droit que
j'ai huit diraison et malheureusement
les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
important comme vous savez dans tous les
domaines nous demandons donc dans le
domaine de la violence également vous
avez effectivement dans les réseaux
sociaux des appels à des recoupements
je pense qu'il ya un problème par
rapport à un débat des bandes qui sont
organisées dans certains quartiers
absolument c'est bon soit démantelée je
sais que c'est pas facile je sais que
c'est compliqué mais il faut absolument
qu'on y travaille avec la police avec
les acteurs sociaux les acteurs
culturels également les acteurs sportive
je pense également je préfère voir des
jeunes sur un terrain de sport ou de
deux ans
une salle de musiques actuelles plutôt
que de s'organiser en bande et de faire
ce genre de violence dont il ya tout un
travail de fond à mettre en place dans
certaines cités dans le monde rural ne
s'est pas la même chose mais où quand
même également on y travaille aussi
merci beaucoup je vois qui me paye au
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france